στα σκάφι όπτημης δε θα ξεγάοκίνη τη μέραν μάιο ήτα αναλλά τσι αρκεδίεστη χωρίς καθόλου
άνεμον και όταν ετιμάσαμε τοπτημης που για όσο δετον ξέρου φαίνεία σα μια μικρή πανιέρα
άλλα είναι το κανήδερο σχολείο για στηπλεγια ταμικρά παιδιά εκάσα μέσα στο σκάφος και έτσι
τα ξίδευψα και στη σία μου λέύρομμεητήσες πήγαινε ση σημαδούρα και έλα και όταν πήγάνε
το υράδη στο σπίτι ακόμα ενιο θα λες καιμε α σας σκάβος ήγε να βάνω
κάτω μέσα στον χρεάτι έτσι λίγον και ήταν πολύ χαρα χηριστηκα αυτό το συνστημα καιο
των βράπη είναι μια στημή που όλοι μουτιζωήτη θυμάμαι και έτσι ξεκίνησε ο παύρος κότης
είσαι στην τελευταία όλη πιάα και αντιλαμβάνεση μέσα στο σκάφος ότε χεις κατακτήσει του άργυρο
ποιον ήταν το συνέημασο μέχρινυγή στη στερια πολλάς είναι σήματα το κατάλαβα στην σία στα
τελευταία πρίμα όταν ήταν αυσταλώς πρώτο σκιερώ δεύτερος αν και πρέπε να περιμέμέχει το τέλος
γιατί αυτός θα μπορούσε ένα σκεφτινά μεσταματήσει αν και δεν το έκανε για τη πορούσε
να χάσιμόνα από εμένα εξζκαι το μάτσρης πυ ήναμε και θα τονανίσουμε και στη συνέχεια
φανταζομε και όταν μπήκαμε συντελευταίνα πρά γιο δρομίαν έτσι έχει μιαν φωτογραφείαν ταν τερματίδο που
βάζωτο βγάζγαλομου και κάνω έτσι με το νερό και το κάνω πάνω και κίνητεα έτσι
αναντιλήφθηκα ότι ήτα όλη την πορεία το δο δεγαχρόον που πέρασαν ήταν ήταν πάρα πολλά
θυμήθηκα τι α απογοητεύσεις ιδικάσυγκεκινά μετά από το τόκιο με τον τρόπο που ήρθεδεααρτη θέσι
και ξεκείνησε να αποκορυφώνεται το συνέσθηματης περιφάνειας και όλα τα χαρούμενα ση εστήματα μετο που
έφτασαν στο σκάβος του προγονητήμο γαή μετά πολύάδευτρόλεπτα πό τηνάπου τερμάτησα